as nevada's largest medical school in a
division of an international university
system toro university nevada college of
osteopathic medicine offers a
distinctive osteopathic approach and it
recently invited us into its anatomy lab
we have the chance to connect with
students the dean and ceo about the
respect given to the students very first
patients
[Music]
second year osteopathic medical student
trinity shaw shares her experience of
holding a scalpel for the first time
little nervous but also a little excited
the first moment when she says she began
her medical journey inside the anatomy
lab of toro university nevada we're all
assigned a particular cadaver which we
work on and either during my time it was
groups of two to four no two bodies are
the same so students can study cadavers
of other groups these cadavers are
donated to toro by the university of
north texas a gift direct learning from
someone who gave their body to science
this is the foundation of medicine
learning all the muscles bones nerves
arteries everything in the body and how
it's all connected it's critical to
their education their mission described
by senior provost and ceo shelley
berkley we have a good faith belief that
when they leave toro and they are
practicing medicine that they are the
best possible providers the learning
achieved inside the state of the art
laboratory is an environment of growth
that carries the students forward in
everything they do an anatomy lab that
is dissection hands-on in my opinion
is not just a rite of passage but it's
also
really one where you learn
professionalism you learn dedication you
learn how to be consistent and
consistently good you learn how to talk
to your partners those are all things
that we take for granted at the end of
the school year an opportunity for the
students to thank the donor in a white
rose donor appreciation ceremony our
moment to kind of give back and show
that appreciation and that humility
to the people who gave us their bodies
and after one school year the cadavers
are sent back to the university of north
texas where they are cremated and
returned to the donor's family